alors ryan c'est grâce à toi que les
médias ont eu vent de ce drame qui vous
touche pense était très important lancé
c'est un drame qui malheureusement
ramènera pas dina ce qu'on aurait voulu
mais qu'a posté ce week-end une vidéo
extraordinaire sur les réseaux très très
touchante c'est un hommage à ta soeur à
la personne qualité je vous propose de
la regarder
[Musique]
même
alors ryan
c'est vrai que cette vidéo elle est
incroyable
quand tu fais pour aller de l'avant
aujourd'hui je vais pas de l'avant
j'y vais pas
elle me manque chaque seconde que
j'avais fait ma soeur me manque
ils me l'ont enlevé
on s'appelait tous les soirs
vous montrer comment elle s habille
lendemain pour aller en cours
on faisait des lunchs time on appelle ça
des lunch times ont mangé ensemble en
festin de vue que j'habitais pas à la
maison
quand ça allait pas ma mère m'a demandé
de l'appeler je l'appelais se confier à
moi
j'essaie d'entrer le maximum les
week-ends et les vacances je passais
tout mon temps avec elle je faisais de
la musique avec elle on écrivait des
chansons chantées
et maintenant et puis la magie et la
puissance j'ai dû l'appeler pour lui
dire que sa soeur était décédé je le
fais en quatre fois alors qu'elle était
déjà morte j'ai pas osé lui annoncer la
nouvelle comme ça je les fais en quatre
fois et c'est au bout de la quatrième
que je vais elle est partie et
comprenait pas qu'on me disait que je le
disais les parties comprenait pas ce que
je voulais dire
comprenez pas j'avais tellement peur de
lui annoncer la nouvelle parce qu'ils
étaient fusionnelle avec sa soeur
je suis désolé rien micro s'excuse m'en
protéger
les yeux non t'excuses pas tout sport
je préfère vivre avec ça à faire j'avais
que ça à faire
c'est pas te
dis pas ça
ryan aujourd'hui c'est quoi ton combat
orangis à ma soeur dans un premier temps
je veux que ses harceleurs et ses
harceleurs el pais il paye c'est pour ce
qu'ils ont fait ils m'ont enlevé ma
soeur ils m'ont enlevé ma soeur j'ai
plus de serge en avait qu'une seule il
me l'a enlevé et je veux qu'ils paient
pour ça
je vais aussi que tous ceux qui qui se
font harceler je me suis par celui ci
étant plus jeune tout ce qu'ils soient
harcelées
qu'ils sachent qu'ils peuvent parler ils
peuvent parler à leurs parents même si
ce n'est pas facile mais c'est pas
facile de se confier parfois ils peuvent
parler
il ya des gens qui sont là pour les
écouter
wafa pas marché pour maintenant pourquoi
ça n'a pas marché pour dinan
on a fait tout ce qu'il fallait on à
aller voir les enseignants on est allé
voir les cités on allait voir la vie
scolaire
ça n'a pas marché
et à la télé par le faisait harcèlement
il parle des programmes jeu et après
quand on va les voir ils nous disent non
sont des gamineries c'est votre fiel en
fait elle en fait un peu trop c'est je
me rappelle d'une semaine
particulièrement ou mais j'étais revenu
chez mes parents pendant une semaine ils
étaient au travail il n'y a pas un jour
où le collège n'a pas appelé trois ou
quatre fois dans la journée pour nous
dire venez la chercher à la par vidal en
cours elle se sent pas bien la mal au
ventre elle a mal à la tête c'est venait
la chercher venait la chercher mais
vraiment tous les jours tous les jours
de la semaine et à aucun moment ils se
sont dit un souci et vient de leur
établissement il ya une carence
éducative et elle vient de leur
établissement à aucun moment ils sont
remis en question le problème il venait
de ma soeur
je vous dit on et ont je pense que les
téléspectateurs sont comme nous on est
révolté par ce qui s'est passé révolté
par le manque de réaction de décision
ryan je me mets à ta place
à un moment tu es tu avoir une aura
jounen gelé tous les jours je vais
toujours j'allais toujours